you're looking at a busy O'Hare Airport
in Chicago US airlines are expected to
fly 47 and a half million people over
Christmas and New Year's and today and
tomorrow will be the two of the busiest
days for air travel one estimate says up
to 3 million Flyers a day will cram into
those Cosi airline seats while the trend
has been for seats to shrink and get
closer together it hasn't stopped some
airlines from devoting years of work and
tens of millions of dollars trying to
find their perfect seat well we asked
Kris Van Cleave to look for one he filed
this report from Detroit good morning we
start our hunt for the perfect airline
seat with this brand-new Airbus a320neo
where spirit is trying something new
their biggest complaint from fliers
their seats are uncomfortable they bring
us along as they try to change that
spirit in airline known for rock-bottom
fares wanted to start with a clean slate
a brand new empty airplane with its
future lined up neatly in rows inside
its Detroit hangar the work begins it'll
take up to 10 spirit employees more than
12 hours to get all 182 seats loaded
into the plane slot it into the right
spot and locked into place if the goal
is to find the perfect seat for spirit
do you think you did it with these I
think this is an amazing seat for spirit
while you Rittenhouse spent more than a
year fine-tuning the new cabin with
particular emphasis on the seats they
have memory foam a new curved back so
passengers sit further back in the seat
opening up more usable legroom while
increasing the amount of pre recline the
rows are still just 28 inches apart but
the airline says the curved design and
moving the seat back pocket to the top
has freed up 2 inches of usable space
and they've added a real tray table oh
and that middle seat it grew an extra
inch now 18 inches wide people are gonna
see this story and go this is all just
an excuse to shrink the space and grab
more people on planes that is not what
we're doing the number of seats are
still at 182 what did change was the
livable space in the seed so from a
guest perspective we wanted to make sure
that they felt that they had a more
comfortable time in the seat for an
airline new seats are a
multimillion-dollar undertaking they're
typically lighter which saves fuel and
thus the airline money but the feel has
to be right
believe it or not Airlines actually want
us to be comfortable industry analyst
Henry Hart developed the see is the
moment of truth if the seat is a bad
seat if the customer isn't comfortable
they're going to remember that
and they won't choose that airline again
spirits new seats take flight as the FAA
is under pressure from Congress to
finish testing to determine the safe
minimum size for airline seats critics
worry those findings could lead to even
more cramped cabins we think that the
airline industry is looking at that
report as a green light to cram even
more consumers into ever smaller seats
we flew with Alaska Airlines frequent
fliers over California's Bay Area for a
sneak peek of Alaska's new cabin the
only rows that got closer together on
this plane were in first class the new
seats created by BMWs design works are
intended to feel a bit like a luxury car
the memory foam is basically to give the
guest Jet Blue has spent years working
on its new cabin the leisure carrier
also went with the curved back seat with
memory foam the distance between rows
stays the same but because the seats
themselves take up less space
JetBlue can add up to 12 more seats it's
incredibly important that we get this
right because Aircraft Interiors do fly
for a long time so we put a lot of
thought into designing what we believe
is the perfect seat the truth is the
perfect airline seat probably varies by
airline but for spirit these new seats
are already in one plane that's out
there flying customers every new plane
will have them they'll take a few years
for the rest of the fleet to get these
new seats which spirit hopes is their
perfect seat for CBS this morning Kris
Van Cleave Detroit are you guys
convinced have to try it
crickets Africa try it get rid of that
middle seat I mean that's what makes it
feel that crowded when you're on an
airplane
just that you're crammed in with other
people that are really close to you and
those seats are not getting wider we're
all frequent travelers here anything
that makes it more comfortable right
literally anything the upgrades are
great everybody upgrade that also nobody
really reclines their seats especially
if you're an economy because you don't
want to ruin the experience for the
person sign you some people honestly I
really about the things that I that make
me comfortable neck pillow lots of
layers
music snacks I have seen Jericka when
we're launched on stories together
Jericka has one of those neck pillows
about her neck I wonder if they really
work
you